>>> AFTER MONTHS OF RACIST
ATTACKS BY THE FORMER PRESIDEN
ELAINE CHAO, HIS FORMER
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION, IS
SPEAKING OUT.
SHE TOLD "POLITICO" IN A
STATEMENT, QUOTE, WHEN I WAS
YOUNG, SOME PEOPLE DELIBERATELY
MISSPELLED OR MISPRONOUNCED MY
NAME.
ASIAN AMERICANS HAVE WORKED HARD
TO CHANGE THAT EXPERIENCE FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND
THAT, WHICH SAYS A WHOLE LOT
MORE ABOUT HIM THAN IT WILL EVER
SAY ABOUT ASIAN AMERICANS.
THIS RESPONSE COMES AFTER HIGH
PROFILE SHOOTINGS TARGETING THE
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
AFTER THE FORMER PRESIDENT
REPEATEDLY USED A DEMEANING TERM
TO DESCRIBE HER.
AS THE EDITORIAL BOARD OF THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL," HER REAL
OFFENSE WAS RESIGNING AS
SECRETARY.
I'M JOINED BY ALYSSA FARAH
GRIFFIN, WHO SERVED AS
COMMUNICATIONS FOR PRESIDENT AND
HAS SPOKEN OUT AGAINST HIS
REMARKS.
ALSO SCOTT JENNINGS, LONG-TIME
ADVISER TO SENATOR MITCH
McCONNELL, WHO IS HUSBAND TO
ELAINE CHAO.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
YOU COVERED DONALD TRUMP A LONG
TIME.
QUOTE, PEOPLE SHOULD STOP
FEIGNING OUTRAGE AND ENGAGING IN
CONTROVERSIES THAT EXIST ONLY IN
THEIR HEADS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT AS BOTH
A REPORTER AND AS AN ASIAN
AMERICAN?
>> YEAH, JOHN, YOU KNOW, I THINK
I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT
ESPECIALLY DURING A WEEK LIKE
THIS ONE, WHEN THERE HAS BEEN SO
MUCH PAIN IN THE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY, THAT SOMEONE LIKE
MR. TRUMP MIGHT HAVE BEEN
THINKING A LOT ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE OF BEING ASIAN
AMERICAN.
YOU KNOW, THERE IS NO FAKE
OUTRAGE HERE.
I THINK THERE IS JUST THE
REALITY.
THAT IS THAT, YEAH, ASIAN
AMERICANS AND ASIAN PEOPLE
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY CONFRONT ALL
KINDS OF RACISM ALL THE TIME.
AND I THINK WHAT IS PARTICULARLY
DISTURBING TO THINK ABOUT THIS
WEEK IS THINKING ABOUT WHEN YOU
SEE AN EX-PRESIDENT MOCKING AND
MAKING OVERTLY RACIST COMMENTS
ABOUT HIS FORMER CABINET MEMBER,
WHAT METHOD THAT MIGHT SEND TO
THE AVERAGE PERSON ABOUT WHAT
MIGHT BE OKAY TO SAY TO THE
AVERAGE ASIAN AMERICAN AND ASIAN
PERSON IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
YOUR NEIGHBOR, YOUR COLLEAGUE,
JUST SOMEBODY WHO LOOKS LIKE ME
WALKING DOWN THE STREET.
AND YOU KNOW, TRUMP, HAS BEEN
STOKING THESE RACIAL DIVISIONS
EVER SINCE HE WAS A CANDIDATE
AND GOING WAY FAR BACK PAST
THAT.
HE DID IT WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT.
AND I THINK WE HAVE NO REASON TO
THINK THAT HE WOULDN'T KEEP
DOING THAT IF HE WERE TO GET
ANOTHER FOUR YEARS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> AND THERE'S NO REASON TO
THINK HE DOESN'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT HE IS DOING.
E
M.J., JUST TO HIT THIS ONE MORE
TIME, WHEN ELAINE CHAO SPEAKS
ABOUT HER LIFE EXPERIENCE,
GROWING UP, PEOPLE
MISPRONOUNCING HER NAME GROWING
UP, DOES THAT STRIKE A CHORD
WITH YOU?
>> IT DOES, AND I THINK IT
STRIKES A CHORD WITH MANY, MANY
ASIAN AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY.
SHE SAID ASIANS HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO CHANGE THAT EXPERIENCE FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
AND SHE SAID SHE BELIEVES TRUMP
CLEARLY DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
I THINK SHE IS CLEARLY RIGHT,
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NO IDEA
HOW EMBEDDED THAT EXPERIENCE IS
IN BEING ASIAN AMERICAN.
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE THE
POINT THAT WE ARE NOT ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT OVERT RACISM OR
COMMENTS THAT ARE JUST SO
HEINOUS OR EVEN BORDERING ON
VIOLENCE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT SORT OF THE
EVERYDAY EXPERIENCE, TOO, OF
JUST BEING MADE TO FEEL LIKE AN
OTHER, THAT YOU DON'T BELONG,
THAT IF YOU LOOK LIKE ME, THEN
YOU MUST BE FOREIGN AND THAT YOU
HAVE TO SORT OF PROVE YOUR
WORTH.
IT IS BEING, YOU KNOW, ASKED THE
QUE
QUESTION, DO YOU SPEAK ENGLISH.
IT IS BEING ASKED, WHERE ARE YOU
REALLY FROM?
IT IS BEING A REPORTER AT A
TRUMP RALLY IN IOWA AND BEING
TOLD MY SOMEBODY, NO OFFENSE TO
YOU, BUT THERE ARE THESE PEOPLE
COMING FROM ASIA ALL THE TIME
AND HAVING FAMILIES HERE AND
TAKING AWAY OUR JOBS.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS,
JOHN, THAT I BECAME AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN BACK IN 2016.
IT WAS ONE OF THE HAPPIEST DAYS
OF MY LIFE.
BUT I STILL -- EVEN THOUGH I'M
NOW AN AMERICAN CITIZEN, GRAPPLE
WITH, I THINK, THAT QUESTION OF
BELONGING AS AN ASIAN AMERICAN,
THAT I BELIEVE IS WHAT ELAINE
CHAO IS TALKING ABOUT.
>> I COUNT THAT AS A WIN FOR THE
UNITED STATES THAT WE GOT YOU IN
2017.
ALYSSA, ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
HAVE HEARD ALMOST VERBATIM FROM
SOME REPUBLICANS IS, OH, TRUMP
JUST LIKES TO CALL PEOPLE NAMES.
THIS IS JUST HIM DOING WHAT HE
DOES.
>> WELL, AND LISTEN, I'M NOT
GOING TO FEIGN OUTRAGE AND
PRETEND I'M SHOCKED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, ONCE AGAIN,
USED RACIST COMMENTS TO ATTACK
SOMEBODY.
THIS IS A PATTERN FOR HIM.
HE'S DONE IT COUNTLESS TIMES
SINCE HE WAS FIRST A DECLARED
CANDIDATE.
I THINK TWO THINGS STAND OUT TO
ME, THE TIMING AND THE TARGET.
AS M.J. MENTIONED, THIS TRAGIC
MASS SHOOTING TARGETING THE
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AND VIOLENCE AND HARASSMENT HAVE
BEEN ON THE RISE, DATING BACK TO
COVID AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES
ABOUT THAT.
BUT ALSO THE TARGET.
THIS IS ELAINE CHAO, SERVED WITH
THE REAGAN ADMINISTRATION, THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION, NATURALIZED
CITIZEN SINCE THEY WAS 19 YEARS
OLD.
SHE'S BEEN IN PUBLIC SERVICE, AN
AMERICAN WHO SERVED IN HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
HER ONLY OFFENSE, OF COURSE, WAS
THAT SHE OPPOSED THE
INSURRECTION.
THE QUESTION FOR REPUBLICANS IS
DO WE WANT FOUR MORE YEARS OF
THIS?
EXPLAINING THE OUR KIDS WHY THE
PRESIDENT OR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS SAYING RACIST,
OFFENSIVE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
YELL AT THEM FOR SAYING ON THE
PLAYGROUND?
THE TURNING THE BLIND EYE AND
RICK SCOTT LIKES TO CALL NAMES.
I'M JUST CALLING HIM OUT THERE.
NO, THIS IS BLATANTLY RACIST.
IT'S THE WORST TIMING, AND IT'S
SUCH A REMINDER WE DON'T NEED TO
DO THIS AGAIN.
>> THE DO WE WANT FOUR MORE
YEARS IS A POLITICAL QUESTION.
BUT THERE'S ALSO A MORAL
QUESTION IS, DO WE WANT FOUR
MORE MINUTES OF A PUBLIC FIGURE
SAYING RACIST THINGS?
AND HOW DO YOU STOP THAT FROM
HAPPENING?
AND WHAT WOULD YOU ADVISE
REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS TO SAY
ABOUT THIS?
I ASK BECAUSE MITCH McCONNELL
HAS BEEN RETICENT AT TIMES TO
EVEN MENTION TRUMP'S NAME.
HE'S DOING THAT ON PURPOSE.
I THINK HE DOESN'T WANT TO
NECESSARILY ELEVATE HIM.
BUT IN A CASE LIKE THIS, DO YOU
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO SPEAK
OUT?
>> I THINK IT MADE SENSE FOR
ELAINE CHAO TO SPEAK OUT
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, SHE'S
CLASSIER THAN DONALD TRUMP WILL
EVER THINK ABOUT BEING.
AND SHE'S LET THIS GO FOR SOME
TIME.
BUT AT SOME POINT IT BECOMES NOT
JUST AN ISSUE FOR HER PERSONALLY
BUT AN ISSUE FOR THE ENTIRE
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
ELAINE CHAO, HER PARENTS, HER
FAMILY, THEY ARE 1,000 TIMES THE
AMERICAN PATRIOTS DONALD TRUMP
WILL EVER BE.
AND FOR HIM TO QUESTION THEIR
PATRIOTISM AND QUESTION THEIR
LOVE OF THIS COUNTRY AND SAY
THEY HAVE SOMETHING TO DO WITH
COMMUNIST CHINA, IT'S ROU
OUTRAGEOUS.
SO, I'M GLAD SHE STOOD UP FOR
THE ENTIRETY OF THE ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AS PRT REST OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, I THINK IF YOU HEAR
DONALD TRUMP SAY SOMETHING
BLATANTLY RACIST, AND YOU CANNOT
SUMMONS THE COURAGE TO SAY
SOMETHING, YOU NEED TO LOOK
INSIDE YOURSELF AND SAY WHAT AM
I DOING HERE AND WHAT DO WE WANT
OUR COUNTRY TO BE?
ARE WE MORAL ENOUGH TO LEAD THIS
COUNTRY?
THE CHAO'S ARE AN AMERICAN
SUCCESS STORY, THE LONGEST
SERVING CABINET MEMBER SINCE
WORLD WAR II.
THIS PERSON IS AN INSPIRATION TO
AN ENTIRE GROUP OF PEOPLE.
REGARDLESS OF POLITICS, ASIAN
AMERICANS LOOK UP TO ELAINE
CHAO.
WE HAVE THIS EGO MANIAC, THIS
INFANT, THIS RACIST WHO
CONTINUES TO MAKE THESE
STATEMENTS ABOUT HER.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
AND EVERY SINGLE DAY, EVEN IF
SENATOR McCONNELL AND ELAINE
CHAO CHOOSE NOT TO WRESTLE WITH
THE PIG IN THE MUD.
THAT'S WHERE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY OUGHT TO STAND.